[Music]
we talked about doctor and we threw such
as a container that they started out
being on the latest platform kind of
evolved from the notion of jailing which
included a way to kind of trap a process
within analytics platform we talked
about how that doctor we talked about
some of the differences between docker
and how they can evolve from Lexy right
Alexeev your call from last week LXE was
a way to kind of isolate resources using
main spaces they've talked about with
Linux and kind of evolved into and
doctor built on top of Alexei maybe that
was their own container they usually
call it container but perfectly the same
thing it's a way to isolate resources no
isolate processes right so that's what
doctor is and so let's talk a little
reminder of some of the other things and
talk about and
[Music]
from last week again we talked about how
if you would if you'd the starting point
you had this thing called a docker
registry right and this dr. registry
right here is essentially a repository
and I know these terms are kind of
overused but this kind of bear with me
just a minute a registry is a repository
or it's a holding unit for a bunch of
images okay so registry holds images
often you'll see in the doctor
documentation that images are often
closely linked to what they called
auditory repository being a base image
of some sort like bun 2 or sent off or
even windows and then what we built yet
last week all the doctor file right so
and without a base image and without a
doctor pile you cannot build an image
okay so yeah so we talked about a
registry it holds it's a place that
holds images or repositories a
repository is essentially the image or
the thing that you're using but it but
it includes a base image of the doctor
file now it's worth to note these images
are read owned like mustard built and
once they're safe you can't read them or
what you can only read from them you
cannot write to them okay all right
from there what on your own Linux box or
on your own Windows box whatever you're
using
we remember last week ran what we called
a docker pool which is a command at the
doctor command followed by the pool
argument this doctor pull went to this
registry right and then in this case
what was the name of the registry
England recall
right it was docker hub
right so in the doctor hub when we do
this from the command line when we do
the dr. Poole it went to the to the
registry ie doctor hub dot-com and it
pulled the specific image that we wanted
and brought it to your local repository
on your Linux box alright so let's look
at that for a minute so can anyone see
my thermal okay
that better
alright alright so just begin to see it
currently I'm just going dr. Mann and if
I just do it
dr. images you'll see in a second from
the look on look
they never give you set McConnell give
me just a minute tell me quick
yeah all right so um so what I wanted
dr. images I don't have any images in my
local repository on my computer right
but if I were to search for one just
give one over some of these commands a
little bit later on
excuse me
how's the search for one I'm gonna go
fix the fence offices because it's just
easier to grab and what I can do is what
this is this search me get the doctor
hub registry that's the default registry
as I search this this doctor hub dot-com
registry and I found for CentOS there
are several images of several
repositories within in the repo that is
the same as we doing this
you
that is the same is been going to docker
hub when you login excuse me
that famous big one here and doing a
search here in doctor hub those same
ones also appear
you
in my when I perform a doctor search
take same exact thing okay
all right so
I'm going to make this big again some
kind of get to it so now what I'm doing
dr. cool like this he goes to the doctor
club and it's going to pull that my
CentOS image or my CentOS repository
right so again it if then if we were to
do a doctor a local doctor images you
would see in my local repository don't
fear this they won't get to the top you
would see that in my local repository
now is this image
okay
and and this way you can see it too
and in English sent us repository you
see a lot of times you can come to this
repo and you can kind of get some extra
information about a few things so it
might be worthwhile coming here take a
look at it so
so balaji today we don't have to worry
about doing doing this in Google cloud
currently and the reason why we're not
doing that today is that because we got
a lot to cover and if you were to do
that it would kind of be tracked it
would allow us to kind of get to the
point that we we get up we're probably
about a lesson behind and I try to make
sure we get caught up so that make sense
so yeah but so again we don't have to do
this in Google cloud but you're welcome
to follow along if you want
all right so no worries about any of
this stuff okay hi um is your question
Balaji
or your point all right thank you all
right not a problem
okay so again so we had this with this
we went to dr. hood calm and we did pull
the repo so but what I want everyone to
do before we do move on
everyone should have a doctor huh
attempt
and if you if by chance you miss we do
not have a doctor hub account
there's going to be important when you
go to try different things but you have
one so I don't give me
so what I have done is I pasted the link
for you all to get in the doctor hub
account so you click on that link you
can go there and register one just takes
a few minutes to do so so definitely
that's something that you're going to
want to do all right so again so back
back to this PowerPoint okay
so again when you perform this dr. pool
it
excellent so we've one point is I can
cool from the repo what happens is
it loads it on your local machine okay
and then this is what's going to happen
and when I do something like this
doctors excuse me
Claire and then when I do a doctor run
we will come back to this command to
this the middle path I'm going to show
your principal dr. Ron that's IT
Cintas I should do it
and if I want to open up another tap the
games it's just so you can see it
and then if we were to do a docker PS
which brings up image you would see that
a container is right okay so here we
have this docker image
and then what we did is that we said one
this doctor in it's in a DES IT means of
interactive of TTY or terminal
essentially so other words give me the
command line so what I did say run this
image in this mode interactive mode and
I'm going to do anything with it but
here you can see when I did the doctor
PS which is the document of to run to
bring up containers not images
components and I can see that my
sentence
container is running
okay now if I were to exit
out of that container and come back and
run that same command you would see that
my container was terminated
okay so here there's a difference
between so this was a part of dr.
includes a registry which holds all of
the images okay not a problem I guess
okay so this role better clip
so when when just backtrack a little bit
so what I did was I ran the docker image
which in turn created a dr. container
right and I did use dr. PS and kind of
list all containers okay so I have a
container running current now containers
are very powerful in that you know you
can you can stop them and get rid of
them fairly easy so when I exit out of
this container right here I see that the
critically I see that there are no
longer any containers running so when I
exited it out it effectively stopped the
container for money that's what I was
pointing out
they make sense
yes okay great
so Praveen said I think the for that we
need ctrl + Q to come out from running
container you go to couple ways quite
honestly it depends on the on the type
of container and where you're running it
like if you're running it in the VM
you've got to be mindful that you're
running it's inside of the VM and
there's a few couple things you have to
do but just strictly speaking of the
container itself exit is the command
they from the command line they get you
out of the out of the container
all right okay all right so let's talk
about a few other things
all right so getting back to this so
what we should understand now in that
that there's a registry that holds a
bunch of images and or repositories
repository an image the same thing again
Gawker world okay a doctor of your
repository or an image is made up of two
things a base image and a doctor file
this repository our image is read-only
no tick tick stop stop it's read-only
all right and what happens is that when
you from your computer
from your computer right when you want
to dis commend dr. Poole
it takes this entire image or repository
it loads it to your local repository so
for every doctor there's a local
repository often is hitting kind of
kitten from hidden from you but if it is
there so Pilate asked questions so what
is base image it is like Linux or sent
off ISO yes s what it's kind of like
that right exactly blood it's like a
base image could be a an operating
system or it could be an application so
if you would let's let's just go to
doctor hub so you can kind of quickly
see it I mean probably more easily see
it here
so
in this
um goats so in this I can come in coming
here and get a different operating
systems let's try the number one trim
toss right I can do
Ubuntu right I'll keep this louis xing
here oh yeah so
[Music]
in Essen Munchen strictly OSX but you
know they have quite a few different
operating systems in here okay but
additionally if I wanted to I can come
and get an application like my sequel or
this one you I think we all heard of
like HDFS Hadoop data file system or
just just put Hadoop right or Hadoop I
can simply go here and grab a a
container and then that will allow me to
do whatever it is that I that I can do
so those are different types of base
images you can get the answer your
question of Elijah
all right excellent okay
all right so now after you pull the base
image right over to your local repo
here's you have it in your local repo
and then what you can do is that you
begin to build what they call layers on
top of this repo and these layers could
be a bunch of thing that uh it could be
that you loaded some file into your into
your content into your container
um
it could be that you have some kind of
software loaded onto your container and
then this container
yes excellent relief yes really correct
doctor history yes that's one way to
take a look at them
another one is doctor inspect as well
right so so you can take a look at these
layers which start again just represent
what's been built on top of the what the
base image okay and then what happens is
is that from once you kind of get it to
where you want I can then take it and
push it back
and then what happens everything I added
now becomes a base image
or repository image in my registry all
right so these are some of those
different things that you can do with it
but the main thing I want the thing I
want you to get here is some basic
understanding of when you see registry
when you see images when you see a
container that you understand the new
watch differences between them all
okay are there any questions
any questions Jerome the overhead doctor
prepare to be home it is much smaller
generally they say that you lose with my
two to three percent of processing power
when you're using containers for bm's
you use somewhere in labor between I 5
to 15%
not a problem
the lodging the probably reason why you
can get instead of want to just doctor
images if you do a pseudo docker images
next you take care of you
and Balaji you you must try phase as we
kind of go forward not a problem there
Balaji so it's not a problem okay
alright but again I'm primarily
demonstrating for those who want to
follow along can
you can do it that way right okay all
right so any questions
Matt upon their Balaji in any questions
not a Hollister go ahead
you
you
all right how much you
um so the so um the OS is it when this
when this base image is downloaded
I don't think you can see the that exact
path that is run that it's in but let me
see something is like a hidden directory
maybe she is an exquisite shitty dot
our solutions
imitating the answers in a hidden
directory I can't quite remember that
hidden directory is to actually see the
raw knockers uh in it but it's a hidden
directory it should be fairly melsby
pretty the fire seemed quite remember
where it is and I can find that out if
you want me to
you
so so we have a couple questions can
actually please explain layering again
and I'll be back then but I think this
this local registry question this is
fairly easy to do here in a few minutes
of the guys we're going to build a local
registry and I'll show you how to do
that okay
right now spit it back to your question
you said layering let's go back to that
right so essentially the point I'm
making is so any image that you pull
from the registry is going to be your
base in it right so if you would
this match so if you would when you pull
it over here and this becomes your face
damage so let me
you
you can look at when you pull it that
kind of really kind of goes away from
most part and then what this really
becomes is your base image another right
this is the base image now okay and then
we've run the container you're going to
do various things if I picked a very
crispy bits load files inside of the
container it could be that you add
software to the container can be a
variety of things whatever you would
only do with computer but every time it
touch me the way that it works is that
each layer represents some kind of what
they call a commit
all right you glare accountants would
commit so I could have did a bunch of
things I could have added software and
filed and a few other things but until I
do this commit that's when it becomes a
part of this layer
and then the next commit would be a part
of the next layer and so forth so
ultimately you'll just kind of keep
building
until it does what you wanted to do and
then what you from here they not take
all of that all the things I've
committed and then it push it to a
registry
and then then that in turn becomes a
base image
the make sense of Smith
all right great all right let's move on
to the next thing
all right so what now so we talked about
the relationship between between this is
looking and an image
so it's going to add is something like
your download image like changes left
load your very own yeah exactly
so you downloading the image then if you
want to then if you want to be able to
kind of review the things that you build
again you push it to your own docker hub
account
correct
exactly right
all right okay so well Larry using that
entire process layering is strictly this
notion of adding something to
adding something to your to your
original repo or original Hemet so in
one place yeah I got ya
all right so so now we understand the
differences between a registry a
container and an in it again images are
read-only containers I can read and
write because it's kind of what I'm
working on right containers use image as
the base okay all right so now that we
understand that so let's start with the
one on the left here this
the Linux this is our Linux box okay so
for Linux again we talked last week
about you know this notion of a kernel
we talked
um yogi I'm sorry so I'm sorry OTS
question is images like the condition in
which the extra school currently is
my surprise let's get the question yogi
before I move on it sounds like you're
asking it is the image is an image is
the life of the base condensed condition
or the base the starting status ah yes
gotcha so for these yes containers is
what is one
right and I think that me
oh okay I got ya I'm a big I see what
you're saying I mean an image is just
like the acting probably closer to what
completes it
it says no she love it's like a tar ball
or a zip file that has all your all your
stuff that you need in order to run
right that's how I said I mean so an
image is kind of like this the starting
point that does this file or a tarball
that has everything you need to run
whatever you're running within that
carbo or within that zip file so I see
that relationship
does that make sense
all right excellent okay so any other
questions on images containers in
registries
we're good alright alright so now that
we understand go one more question can
we modify an image at our end and make
it as our copy yes you can you can do
that and we're going to talk about that
a little bit later
alright alright so now that we
understand the relationship between the
container image registry let's talk a
little bit about the software ok the
software that makes all this work
together ok so I'm looking at a Lynch
box you have a again for the most part
doctor and containers only work within a
Linux environment
just kind of follow I'm saying don't
just to any conclusions right now just
just just kind of truck along with me
doctor containers currently only work
within a Linux environment I talked
about what I mean here in a minute
ok so in this minute environment you
have a kernel we talked last week about
the Union SS Union filesystem is kind of
what allows you to do different versions
or different branches of a current file
system and kind of build other layers on
top of that so that you can have
different types of file systems to
include like NFS Exe for whatever you
can have different types on top of this
new file system on top of these file
systems are these controllers all right
we thought I guess they are C groups as
we refer to them right and C groups is a
way to kind of isolate resources all
right now resources and processing as
well okay now here what we have is the
doctor engine this doctor engine is the
API for doctor doctor engine is the
client for a doctor
oh I got you much control groups okay
all right dr. engine emphasis color
quick doctor engine is the API it's the
client and it's the daemon for dr. a
daemon is a process there was in the
background that's what as bayman is okay
so doctor we say dr. images we're
talking about for the most part all
things we need to run a container on a
particular machine okay that's a doctor
engine all right now uh last week of
Elijah to get to your concealer question
we talked about these namespaces okay
don't forget a namespace was a way to
restrict how price what processes that
one have access to so I have a name a
network namespace anything that's kind
of network related with one under that
namespace so it's a way to kind of
isolate processes it's a way to isolate
different types of underlying resources
so a network of process running a
network namespace may not have direct
access to changing user information
right because there's a user name space
and any time a process whether that user
name space can have access to the user
name space resources right so these
namespaces are a way to isolate
resources are only kind of make
available the resources that it have
access to so this is a practical example
a lot of times you build these main
spaces when you only want certain
processes to have access to like two
gigabytes of memory you want to only
have access to one core right one core
being one CPU associate with your
machine you don't wanted to have access
to a particular network and all that can
be done by creating these control groups
these control groups allows you to
isolate resources that make sense
obliging
and the reason why you might want to do
this again is so that not one
application that you run or what not one
process eats up more resources being you
wanted to eat up because there's nothing
worse than a rapid of application or a
random process that's killing all your
memory eating up all your disk space and
so forth and it happens
right so what happened is that because
of doctrine engine is
[Music]
it is the doctor application that that
is used to control the API the client
and the doctor Damon
again the daemon is just a doctor
process that ones in the background all
it is okay so Balaji asked a question so
dr. engines developed evening which
language I think the combination quite
honestly I do think that primarily there
is a notion of goal and that's gonna if
our call organisms see in there as well
SEPA fluff
but if you were to go just real quickly
I'm kind of curious to you want to go to
dr. github
come again it is all open source if you
were to go to any of these code code
bases I think you can kind of get to the
core of what it's built in yet so it
shows so you have some go-go language is
a part of it
yeah I think most of it is in go
yes gold language that's my mother
all right
are any other questions for you keep on
not a problem alright so again you had
this doctor engine and this doctor
incident is what's used to run these
individual containers it kind of eyes
the infant or to London's okay now to to
execute on a single container you simply
use the doctor command
that will allow you to start stop and
properly to settle from one container
but sometimes we need to control
containers in groups
right or kind of spin up ten containers
to do ten of the things as are the
application and that event will unite
Assyrian I'm sorry you need gossip
compose
right and uh propose is
[Music]
let's suppose it allows us to one of the
local machine so with super deep with
with dr. suppose you don't have an
option to commit but you don't have to
because there's an actual if you would a
deal file for ducting proposed so you
can tell it to to to build all these
different things and then you can take
that then that makes memo which is a
type of language or type of figuration
for the doctor to compose and you can
save that and share that and then that
way anybody can use it to build your
doctor
so there's no need to quote unquote
comes doctor to mix for that alright
alright so now again it's oh yeah so
over here this is your base this is kind
of what we're going to base everything
else from going forward okay all right
any questions about doctor or Linux
all right great all right so now we have
Windows Windows and OS X okay just how
does Windows and OS X implement docker
okay so just like Linux Windows and OS X
both have a kernel which handles all
those to reach all the managing of the
resources below hard drive that were you
know all the hardware etcetera okay but
what Windows and doctor will Windows OS
X good for you
in order to use the containers innocence
we have to spin up a VM
or that's were so when you say when you
say doctor one here it just kind of
spins up a container or lettuce when I
say doctor one or Windows it spins up a
VM and in each VM there the container
that's right
when I run doctor run on Mac by default
it uses the Mac OS hypervisor but I can
make it use VirtualBox or a few other
ones but nonetheless it's going to spin
up a VM and it's going to have a
container inside of that VM that house
of doctor works on Windows and in Mac OS
and then what happens is essentially it
creates a Linux environment
inside of a deal
is the same stuff that's over here
all right so but till the so what's the
difference the difference is is that
Windows and Mac both uses a VM too and
they kind of build a Linux box inside it
at the end
all right any questions about that
all right now so here's the nice thing
in also
so a test ask the question if we have to
configure a VM separately to run
containers on windows how does it prove
to be cost-effective if you're currently
take caution friend of money it's
because everything is free and open
source right so doc doctor on Windows
Windows comes with the hyper-v VM
already it's already been
so there's no further calls ie money
that you'll have with that
okay so I'll just leave let me clear
this spring
so
you
so yeah
so again on your windows box this is how
it works or oh and click for that matter
you don't have to worry about a car home
because the kernels already there
there's a Windows kernel that does that
operates the windows the windows the way
that needs to work ok you don't have to
do anything else
hyper-v our automatically comes with
your Windows machine just like Mac OS
hypervisor covered with Mac machines you
don't need to do anything else
those already come with the Windows OS
in the Mac OS X respectively
ok so doctor knows that doctor knows
that this has Windows has the hyper-v
and a know that Mac has the OS
Matt well advice so nothing unique this
so when you download
so when you go to
doctor
when you go to download docker from you
know the site that is here which is you
download a user
you got it here to download the
community edition so when you go to
download any of these types of docker
instances essentially what you're going
to end up having is it knows how to use
the hyper be the Mac OS I provides
already so no need to dedicate any
special environment none of that it's
all there ok
now within the scope
of some so what's the DM started again
when you got me when you just simply run
docker one image name whatever it is you
know sent off with is your old Windows
Windows Mac or Linux
if I was running that command there it
would simply oops cute
it would take off on Linux it will kick
off a container only
on Windows it will pick off a deal first
and then it would build the container
inside of that deal with Matt it would
take off the VM first and then we'll
build the container it will run the
container inside of that VM that all
happens automatically
does that make sense
not great look that a problem okay
yeah because you can run doctor in diems
what you can also do is create VM host
for doctor
using doctor machine
yes come yes bloody run sudo not sue sue
in the command but sue those when you
arrive
you
all right so again it so because I was I
can run doctoring vm's what I can do is
I can create my VM host using docker
machine so let's kind of point that out
the tech alright so back to my channel
so in this case I am on OS X
oh do you hear me sorry
all right good okay so here's what I was
saying I was saying that in hyper so for
Windows
there's hyper-v that's that's the
hypervisor that Windows uses when you
runs doctor it builds the VM first and
that VM that it builds is a Linux VM
and in spite of every minutes p.m. are
the individual container that you win
right to the answer questions wrong
you
we get
okay
okay yes
oh I know so the container itself so the
actual container itself will run
whatever it's supposed to do so lightly
so like I think the actual version of a
limit that it runs it like in the VM is
like something called Alpine or call
correctly Alpine lens VM is what it is
but if I download a sentence box the
container will be a sent off box or as
you mixing if this is will be a is
Kattan
all right all right um any other
questions for the law
so lobbyist question had to a do they
download different versions of fence
house you have to really kind of search
for that's the awesome answer this might
go back to dr. hood so like if I wanted
since excuse me I want to sent off six
point seven
you see I can go here and download a
specific container that's more than six
point seven
or if I want to get the latest version
you see here that in this case it cuz
you the version that it is and then the
other things you can do is that a part
of this tag so just as you see it
so
[Music]
you
so I'm just like there so I think this
is it might make it oh get it for me if
I do it this way
yeah so let's do it slow six point six
laps
yes see this that tag allow him cool
diversion for the doctor or whatever
else I want but the way that I know that
is by going into the doctor hub and kind
of reading the documentation to be kind
of tells you what's available
and yeah and this version very
specifically is is in this doctrine I
should notice it doesn't have anything
before six point six so if you want to
five six point five this is point two
that may be mixed it means that may be a
little bit more challenging
all right
alright alright yeah okay so let's go
back to this here so so here's what
we're going to do in this I'm going to
show this again I'm gonna slow FX this
is a Mac and I'm gonna kind of show you
the relationship between doctor machine
the dr. Samantha way you can see it okay
alright so if I were to do this
oops sorry and nobody in the doctor camp
tab tab tab is a ways in the UNIX based
system kind of see what available
commands are commands are available but
here I did is dr. cats have and I see
that I can run there's something called
doctor doctor compose doctor credential
OS X keychain and doctor machine okay
we're talking about whether this is a
specific to OS X you won't have to worry
about it but it's a way to kind of add
document conventions to in Mac within
the scope of what's called a keychain
which is essentially a list of view main
passwords it's got like a bit of terms
that's kind of lifted really secure but
unless I have doctor I had duck and
compose and doctor machine we're going
to find my doc of compose next week all
right so here if I were to do a doctor -
question mark this pool I'm sorry doctor
- health that has helped this pool of a
list of arguments that I can use with
the doctor command to perform different
options principally with doctor machine
again which is a command I can do the -
- help
then I have a list of commands I can run
with the doctor machine command okay
again doctor machine is the tool that's
used to control virtual machine hopes
Virtual Machine host so so what I'm
going to do is that I'm going to create
a docker machine okay so how much hell
is to create one and to create a doctor
machine and in my case I wanted to use
VirtualBox so I'm gonna tell if the
driver is going to be VirtualBox right
- there's one for Amazon Web Services
there's one for Google there's one for
being like digital ocean and a few other
ones that when you run doctor machine
and you understand it allows you to to
create a VM on those other cloud type
platforms okay but here I'm going to
create in this case on me I'm gonna
create one on VirtualBox on my local
machine and I'm going to name it simply
learn okay so I'm creating a doctor
machine or a doctor working with a
docker container host and I'm creating
it using VirtualBox and I'm going to
name that simply learn let's just do
this let me have some characters behind
it just kind of build uniqueness right
so I'm going to do that i'ma press Enter
alright and it's going to go through
some process
so Vlado you ask a question and if you
give me a few minutes I well the driver
is this I'm gonna pipe it into the text
II project - um what's it called console
name right it sounds like this
and that console name thought up I
messed up on the gimmick sugar
you
there you go yeah then a second one is
right
so simply whatever you're the console is
in Google Cloud that's what you would
have to do in it and you would have to
do okay
in a problem so if I do it alright now
again you so you often see it
I'm rigging a virtual box and you see
that now that saying
oh we're thats a machine that i created
again so here's what i did what i just
did
so again we talk about how that Windows
and Mac OS they build bm's for doctor
okay but essentially what I did is I
took we've even got the machine I can
build a doctoral host
I'm dr. Ho's that or if you would be a
of the undead experience running
containers right so it means if I show
you actually when talking about each
second so so here I'm going to do a
doctor - machine and I'm doing LS and so
I have two doctor hosts
to dr. Hodes
in my case but the one I just created
was this one called simpler and notice
how it's a VM that's running on by OS
Xbox currently ok now what I can do in
here I can do dr. machine SSH simply
and what this does is very similar to
how you eat kind of interest a sore
already to other boxes I'm going to bite
one of this document into layer I'm
going to access the command line from
this machine so now I'm in this simply
learning machine right if you were to do
a you name you would see that this uses
a Linux kernel and specifically a uses
boots doctor which is a lightweight
version of Linux that has doctorís type
commands not precise dependencies and to
magical rod ok so again all I did was
create this VM so doctor machine will
have a decrease in VM
um
[Music]
and into that and so in this way we're
only using doctor only without
necessarily having to use all the putty
that SSA Qing and all those different
things this might be a benefit to doing
that
but you very well could I stick into it
in the way that you would do that I
would you know the question was how
would you know the IP to run off to
officer exit here I can see my IP
address associated with this particular
instance so I could sink into it the
normal way but doctor machine gives me a
nice easy way to do it without one
through all that all right I think in
machine
all right any other questions
the answer questions' litter
yes yeah I guess um I think I'll make
reassigned to the machine dynamically
something you like to worry about to the
VM excuse me
and there's a way they're different like
you can be as specific as you want you
can assign it a particular IP of core
al-qaida stuff right I mean the list
goes on and on how you do is kind of
things but so but it's like default
which is just kind of sizing through it
automatically
so like what this way you can see it
again
doctor machine create tick - - help and
what this does it will show you all of
the arguments you can pass the create
command oh sorry
oh these are all the different things
that you can do you can kind of set up
memory warming's a way to manage that
we're talking about again next week you
can set up IP addresses different labels
environment variables all kind of things
right so but nonetheless if you want to
kind of pointed out to you that that
last command that I ran doctor machine
create that guy's help this is the
argument and this dentist helped provide
it will show you all the arguments to
pass for this other create okay all
right any others
you
so Milani yes the question you can there
are some tabs like active arrows there I
think we here
are you frightened where I am or
necessary talking about things in it
you
Oh
we take from each other some tasks
active and errors I'm not sure if I
understand balagia so if you can provide
some clarification I hopefully I can
answer your question all right okay so
why do I committed Balaji I've waited
and can move on so this this doctor
machine
so again all I did was create a host it
is here if I wanted to build different
VMs
I'm sorry so now I'm in that dr. post
that I created be a doctor machine I
know it because I see the user which is
the doctor user I'm on this host okay so
what what I can do here is I could do a
doctor search for sent off again just to
kind of see it and if I wanted to add it
here
that's a let's ask this one here this
way we can see it this look a Escala
birds love sent off so I'm gonna say dr.
Poole that birds listen to us alright it
looks like a few minutes is kind of
download and get hopefully it's not that
big I don't think
and these are the different layers that
is downloading
so when they built this image is like
four different layers that it has to
download
all right so now if I want to do a
doctor images I would see that I have
this Harris Harris Todd since off Scala
and it's only in this simply learned
being so watch this now just watch
scared I'm going back to my to my local
machine my Mac o OS X and if I do a
doctor images here guess what I don't
see
that one here
this image that just downloaded so again
this doctor image is the wave
Balaji it was a totally totally random
image Japan the only point was to show
you that what I do here in my in the
doctor machine that I created doesn't
affect what I do hope tuning huh what I
have on my local machine that's totally
it and so in Balaji so but to answer
your question Scala is a type of
language so all that means that they
loaded all of the scholar dependencies
for one bad language in a sprint hotspot
right
all right great all right so we saw so
we see that this kind of machine is
different then the dot so okay so I'm
going to come out of this dr. machine
and I'm back on my Mac okay so let me
clear this so we absolutely have it all
right so what I'm going to do next is
this so by default when I run this dr.
command here
it is only for my machine for my Mac in
this case my OS X but what if when I won
this dr. command
I wanted to effect a specific a specific
dr. machine that I created how do I do
that
so the way that I do that I can run this
two men I can eval eval the way this
bill is a is a UNIX command that allows
you to build other two-man simply's with
this so what I'm going to do them i'ma
run this email come in and I'm gonna
pass it
ah
so below I'm sorry so belonging as do we
need to pull from the machine the local
machine that we go
better not the same thing as a registry
okay we're going to build a registry
later on but one the only point of me
showing you the doctor machine is to
show you how you can separate
being from your local environment
right okay so again so what I'm doing
now is I'm getting ready to build a
command that will allow me to link
what's going on in this in this one
specific terminal to what's going on on
that docker machine that I created okay
so what I can do that i can say docker
machine and then i'm gonna run this
environment variable and actually before
I do that came to the dock machine I
created so give a second sorry
various okay so I'm saying this
environment and then I'm going to do
this okay so what this is doing is that
it's saying build this command that's
simply going to link this doctor machine
to this specific terminal okay so I'm
waiting press Enter Oh sir we got a got
application mark there okay now watch so
now when I when I do docker images it
shows what was in my the doctor machine
that I created
so now I can do this for my native
terminal without having to go to dr.
Machine deficits without having to go
inside of the doctor machine that I
created and doing dr. images is right
there they're linked okay now that's
only for this once to the terminal if I
go here and try to run this same that
sends a man notice is back it's still on
my machine and it pulls up my machines
local repo
this command only works for the terminal
that you running it
right
you
okay any questions
right so split xpresso so we have a
Linux box we just installed dr. and get
going but if we have non Linux machines
then we need to use doctor machine come
in is that so
not necessarily because the doctors what
so doctor machine allows you tighter
control of the VM that doctor runs off
but if you don't have a problem with the
default it's not a problem
all right and so the other thing that
doctor machine allows you to do by again
that this lot of them so I'm not gonna
get into a big wall
statements are big long discussion about
it but I have a link here though I'm
going to share with you
um not quite as good
dr. machine drivers drivers drivers
drivers
you
um okay this is probably one is worth
you have it all right I'm gonna be i
finnaly just a minute give me this doing
it um dr. machine drivers
so again doctor machine allows you
teacher
they have a vm r vm capable that fact
here's a list of them
there I sent you two ways so that second
link brings you to this one these are
all the different places where DMS Milan
on every single one of these are VM bass
and so what I can use is those riders
right those drivers you know and I use
VirtualBox in my face but the point
being you can use all those different
types of drivers that we just that we
see here and create container videos on
those different platforms so why use dr
machine typically if I gotta go throw
between different environments like a
Google cloud my local AWS then maybe the
answer is I use dr. machine versus the
doctor command because that gives me a
greater control of the VM but even once
I get into the VM right and what I mean
by getting to the DM
you
it's here now from here I can run the
doctors man once I'm on the host or in
this in Vienna right so doctor machine
allows me to control the VM host that
I'm creating
but still I need to get to the host to
run to run the different types of
containers
all right
you
so so then see if I can come up with a
little more example so give it a lot of
stuff
so here I have a
this is my window locks windows all
right
and all my windows box
I can do
my windows box I can do a I can run
docker
or
come on doctor machine
so why would I use doctor machine doctor
machine allows me to create
BM BM host there one containers
VM host and this could be on Google
Cloud right
you can be on
we have services well whatever read of
the matter but it allows me to
essentially create these beams for that
read with a doctor
essentially what it allows me to do
is kind of just create table containers
on long windows my local windows box
or principally the same thing here you
know about to do it I would run doctor
on this on this particular machine
it would allow me to create my
you
but once is up and running then I have
to run then dr. command
make sense
all right any other puppies
all right
all right so so that's the docker
machine we talked about the dr. engine
again the dr. engine includes the API it
includes the if you would the difference
being if you want to look at something
doctor the doctors man its nature this
clear the doctor command is for most
parts that's all the stuff that the
doctor engine doctor machine that's that
the doctor machine okay all right
and doctor machines generally they used
to to deal with VM right eye one kind of
stressed that point all right so um
that's that's that so so now that now we
understand that there's those we have
just docker command which kind of let
you do but that's doctor effects the
doctor engine doctor machine does just a
defective doctor doctor machine and we
talked a little bit about a doctor
suppose it allows you to maintain or
affect multiple containers okay all
right so that one's a little bit a
little bit about the architecture in the
software let's kind of move on to a few
other points okay now um docker it's
doctor again the starting point is
always going to be like this docker file
and some base image we talked a little
bit about a little bit about it last
week and we created a doctor file and we
built one right and the example that we
gave me go to my slide deck
you
you
you
here we go all right so we talked about
this and in the doctrine container we
had several several key directives right
you recall we had from with one of them
which tells it the starting image but
there are other directives as well okay
there are other directives as well so
again if you have this build and then
there's build you have this doctor file
which is the starting point and you have
a base in it so you have from which is
kind of where it starts from which is
just the base image but additionally
what you can do is that you can identify
who the maintainer is we'll all right
swimmer that may be but then you have
this other command you can run like
shell from it here
and Michelle a cat allowed to do just
that it allows you to
take the [ __ ] one shelf immense redoes
no matter which one they are here but
they're not either one she'll come in
and particularly for lettuce is pretty
powerful and then you have copy tack
again all this little doctor file this
this this cop attack allows you to copy
source files and source directories to
add to your build
okay this look this is what that copy
allows you to do
The Dispatch man copies the files and
kind of points to URL that you can get
ahold of what's going on my computer
just moved for all right so in this case
is say ad be a tarball to the OP
directly inside of my container that's
how it's going okay now this run this
run pad it allows you to run again some
linux commands to affect how your
sometimes which in this case yum is a
way to manage dependencies RPM is a way
to install some software packages and
then in this case the last one here i
told it to go into two chains rific to
the OP directory and then create a link
from the tarball that i from the tar
ball that i understand that's all it did
all right
additionally I could set environment
burbles but simply type in E&D you know
and so these are all tags within that
doctor file
and lastly this command file allows kind
of set the default application so if
there's something default you want to
run you can set it here
so the difference between this CMD and
this lon run you could put a series of
different things you can run through
commands you go on this CMD kind of
defaults the whatever you want to run by
default when you won the container
itself that's what that is and then let
me do this last week as well then from
there we go doctor bills - t and we're
going to name it something and then
you're telling us this period says in
this directory or you can list the
Studer file that you wanted to run - ok
any questions about the doctor file
okay so I mean when you whenever you
build a image listen this is probably
the good starting point you want to have
a docker file that you can build
yourself but how about typically when
you download an image there's no need
for you to add at direct actors to the
docker file unless you're going to
change it to some degree
you
all right
any questions alright um um so let's go
ahead and move on to this other keep one
because somebody asked about how can we
get our own local registry okay so
building your own local registry all
right so we talked about it in dr. hood
how it's for registry and we talked
about how that we could build this
registry and it's what holds your images
so again you can do that but then uh the
thing you got to think about when you do
that you have to think about you know
why do I want to do that is it is there
a reason for that
because you're going to have to consider
security issues access control how do
you verify that the image is safe by
defining images and you know with
different um hash hash generators and so
forth so there's a lot that kind of goes
into it but nonetheless you can create
one again we talked about how registries
the services of medicine distributing
images but what happens is is that we
can we can take these registries and we
key that we Emil and this simply load
our doctorate images into that right so
the way that that works I think we
talked about this already
dr. hub dr. hub is your default registry
right but it's just as simple as
changing the little miniature running
sum so let's go ahead and create a
registry just so you can see that so I'm
going to create a rich a registry here
and so let me already give it a let me
go into my directory not for the buck
machine
it's a quiet this is a doctor machine
that I created for this class so if I do
a doctor images I see that I already
downloaded the registry
Tanner right so if I would do something
like dr. Poole registry tag - it will
pool of that specific registry all right
our deficit next to the container so
what I want to do is I'm going to run
that container let me make this
fullscreen so that we can follow along I
can't see your your your question so
just give me a minute and I'll get
through it then I go back to look at
reviews there's any questions ok so
again I'm creating a private registry so
what I can do here is like in kind of
say doctor one and this - D this means
one of the background quite detached
right and then what I'm going to do them
put the - P here and that that kind of
tells me by port so I'm going to I'm
going to map
a this this machine this wire machine is
this user at this machine I'm going to
say this is my VM on my host port and
this is the port I'm mapping to in my
container okay so this creates a map
between your hopes and your container
alright and so I might add another
command and I'm gonna say restart always
and then I'm going to name this my
container registry right and then the
image I'm going to run is registry - all
right so this dr. will will pick off my
registry and again it has all the
registry stuff that you need and it's
going to be is going to run this
registry on port 5000
and this dance has restarts allowed me
to restart the registry once once I once
I log out okay
what I do
oh sorry it was a two dashes okay all
right so now if I do a dr. of PS I see
that my hem which is running that I made
the registry to okay and there it is so
I see that my registry is now running so
now what I'm going to do is I'm going to
pull an image from dr. hub okay matter
of fact immensely let me take some
network with images
you
had worked through some of this already
and I want to I want you know to kind of
see what's going on right so there are
my wings remove images not containers
images so what I do a doctor images I
see I no longer had that okay so let me
clear this get you back to the top
let me see there if you have any
questions are good
all right so again I'm feeling my in my
in my my doctor via more doctor machine
so next time I do is I'm going to pull a
bunch you from the doctor hub
okay and now I'm going to do that but
I'm also going to tag it the same way
when I pull it as Ubuntu and I won't put
it in
you
my registry container again don't forget
it with map to port 5000 localhost is is
the default IP address assigned to it
but here I have localhost 5,000 and then
what I'm going to do is I'm glad I just
tell it I'm on when it has a bunch of so
now you see that it downloaded the image
but with it again I'm still in dr. Wyatt
and if I do a doctorate images so to do
that it took and put it there in my
local repo okay now
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
delete that
Ubuntu image again okay
so when you see it it's not there and my
local repository but again here
this command I loaded it in my in my
registry okay but what I want what I'm
going to show you is I'm going to pull
it for my registry and put it back to my
local repo so in order for me to do that
I just want to show you that in my local
repo I know I don't have that button
okay now so what I'm going to do is I'm
going to do a dr. pool but instead of
just kind of not putting anything then
just kind of put it in his name I'm
going to tell it with you registry I
want to put it from so I'm putting from
that same registry and I'm saying bring
me back that a bunch of image okay
just our skin I'm so sorry
here's why it didn't have it in there
cooking so i'ma grab this again
dr. images is on my local repo you see
it here what I forgot to do is push it
excuse me about that so what I'm going
to do from there is I'm gonna do a
docker
push localhost 5,000 and bunches like
that
and it's pushing for my local repo to
the registry so I forgot that that push
should start with that
so now that I've pushed it
I see that in my local reports go ahead
so I'm a little bit for my local repo
and you see that in my local repos gone
so now when I go back to
pull it from my local host
you see that it grabbed it and now I
have it back
alright alright right here I had it
right here in my sleep oh okay
so that's how the registry works
so
[Music]
so book melodia I'm asked a question by
NN is right is these four combining
commands together it's always four to do
this one and then and then do this
and thank you smoother for helping
answer my question okay
yes all right so
it is that for the registry
um this she let me spike get a
PowerPoint here registry
you
you
all right so what we did here is that
again so we can see it
our starting point was we we downloaded
the registry container from get it
github that was the first thing then the
next one we did is that
the next thing that we did was we
started the registry container right
then we did that by this command here
now posted in the
we did it by running that command right
that's how we started our container on
port 5000 our registry contain on port
5000 once it's on the container
we doubt we download it image from a
docker hub
so the logic asked the question of how
the registry is set using above them in
because the registry is already in the
container all I did was in that - P that
tells it which port to map from the
container to my red to my local machine
the dash D means just kind of one into
the background and then what I'm in the
- name - the - name is what I use to
name the container don't get to get
images
to name it registry and then I told us
to pick up the registry can image
version two
and when you do that that was the neck
that calls the Tibet that rich frickin
pants a lot
so black but I be asked a question is
there any court related constraints like
Tomcat F is no there's not
you might like I think all the similar
reports might do something different I
recall correctly like the porch like
that's above like the things what is it
35,000 or some like that you might have
to do some different mappings but for
the most part it still should work
so it's going to ass so we are creating
our own registry and making this one an
entertainer
yeah so this what we're doing which is
we took our our own registry and we're
running it in a container exactly what
we did
yeah
all right and then so and this is what
we did we downloaded this we downloaded
a bunch of from docker hub and then from
there we pushed the above to container
to
registry
that's all we did
all right
you
from
so to just point out there are other
doctor registries just so you know
doctor hub is quite the primary one but
Google has a virgin
aw has one a quail Belize double film
they have one big can create your
private registries right so I mean this
way to do this it matter of fact that
where I work we have our own private
risk of our own private of registry as
well and in that way you know we kind of
keep everything private that way okay
um she gloves
Oh how does this is my son else's that
we need to do to this dr. long indexed
as you name so by default when I want
when I when I won this this was I when I
was going to pull and twist when I push
to doctor it's gonna I need a doctor
login to put that to work so that
command will loud will allow the system
to know who I am
right and then to miss what we talked
about earlier you know how do you create
these big images essentially what you're
going to have to do is you're going to
create a container
and then you're gonna commit it
to a particularly particular kick sorry
but you're going to commit this
container they ain't Java and this is
what you're going to submit it we put it
in dr. this is going to be the man and
then when you push it it pushes out to
your doctor hub repo
Balaji that is the user made that you
that you will use in this case then one
the doctor of absolute prick
all right um tell my doctor dr. Poole
already we're talking about the leading
till he saw me do this where you can do
the doctor RMI now I want to point
something out to at least worth
mentioning
so if I did a knock of PS I see that the
doc PS it lists all my docker containers
that are running so here I see that I
have one docker container running
one dr. caner one so so here um listen
you do so in my when I get a doctor
images I see that I have this doctor
image so if I wanted to remove a doctor
image I just do RM I
dr. main mean image name
interesting to do a force for for that
delete and then when I get that you see
that the name of that image is no longer
in my local repo at all okay quick now
here I have this dr. PS about it at this
container running now watch this this so
we can see it
you
I'm telling him to remove this container
and this container I knew was there
because of when I wearing the dr. PS I
saw that this was using the containers
that I wanted so when I do that it says
this you cannot remove this container
because
Oh
you're running it what if I didn't care
I can just so be do something like this
and then that removes the container
right
all right so let me see all right
some lobbyists question so if we run
that on my command and delete the
repository or image can we restore the
image from a pop story yes but you have
to do a dr. Poole again that's all hey
once become an expert in cloud computing
then subscribe to simpler channel and
click here to watch more such videos
turn it up and get certified in cloud
computing click here